trump attackiert nägeln der grund us
bürgerin medienmarke ruf mittwoch
zusammen mit ihrem mann prinz harry die
amerikaner dazu auf bei der us-wahl ihre
stimmen abzugeben
alle vier jahre wird uns gesagt dies ist
die wichtigste wahl unseres lebens aber
diese ist es wirklich den namen trump
hat merken in ihrem aufruf übrigens
nicht erwähnt doch der fühlt sich
trotzdem angegriffen
ich bin kein fan von er ich wünsche
harry viel glück er wird es brauchen der
ja da kann man schmunzeln oder mal ganz
völlig gestürzt sein
sie schütteln den kopf nicht ganz so
voll das ist nicht mein fallen während
also die art glaube haben wir dann recht
was mal was meinen sie
also erstmal dass er das dass er das
überhaupt aufnimmt finde ich es schon
spricht ja für sich dass ein
amerikanischer präsident ist sozusagen
nötig hat und sich dann da in so ner in
so einer lapidaren bemerkung darüber
auszulassen finde ich absolut unpassend
überflüssig und und überrascht dass
jetzt also das gesagt hat also trump
überrascht mich nicht
also da das finde ich wenig überraschend
weiß ich aber interessant an dieser
geschichte finde es schon ich meine
prinz harry sagt ja auch ganz deutlich
er dürfte noch nie im leben wählen er
ist eigentlich als roy dazu verpflichten
sich zurückzuhalten mit politischen
aussagen
und ich finde er lässt sich schon ganz
schön krass davon mengen vor den karren
spannend also alles im sweet insa
folgenden jagen und plötzlich sitzt du
da in beverly hills und gibt politische
statements und support
wenn diese abgeklemmt ich aber nicht
also ich finde die aussage als
befremdlich weil nur weil megan royal
geheiratet hat heißt das ja nicht dass
ich nicht sagen kann was sie fühlt und
was sie denkt und es ist was völlig
normal ist in den usa auch viele
prominente die woche kein bezug haben
zur politik sprechen wahlempfehlungen
aus und die reaktion von trump ist ja
eine reaktion auch auf ihre
wahlempfehlung für beiden und insofern
finde ich es ganz schwierig zu sagen
dass zum beispiel auch megan sich dazu
nicht äußern sollte weil sie mit harry
verheiratet ist ich glaube das ist ja
ein zeichen dafür haben sie sich davon
gelöst hat und vor allem ja der titel
abgegeben pflichte abgegeben und sich
orte können sich also nicht auch klein
und ich würde mir ehrlich gesagt total
wünschen wenn man in deutschland offen
über politik sprechen würde die sprache
sehen wir ja auch die mccanns zu seiner
politischen ikone hoch ich mag es ja ich
die schauspielerin und hat sich
allerhöchstens für seehunde shelter
eingesetzter hunde in not
also werden sie ist jetzt dass sie wurde
ist deren stimme irgendwie im
politischen amerika bisher vermisst
wurde ist kann sich jeder ein sitz mehr
will ich finde aber dass diese ehe
zunehmend ein bizarres bild ab wirft
also wie sollte sie sich dann verhalten
seiner meinung nach schon in den dom
sollten deshalb für uns findet zum
beispiel mal in seinem buch gesagt
beziehungsweise lässt sich da natürlich
nicht zitieren sondern großvater und so
weiter die hatten alle privilegien die
haben schlösser die haben bediensteten
die können sich die charity aus der ist
im platz acht in der thronfolge die
können sich wirklich einsetzen in seinem
heimatland das war ja alles bewusst
bevor sie dieses mal geheiratet hat mir
kommt es zunehmend so vor so hat nach
beverly hills ich kann hier nicht die
ganze zeit im regnerischen wales und dem
ring an dritte dass das gerade du das
sagst eine so starke frau mit so einer
eigenen gerät heute übrigens ja so dass
ein mann und die haben natürlich haben
die bediensteten natürlich haben wir
alle privilegien die gewann der davon
können sie in liesing deutschland ja nun
eindeutig ein bisschen anders natürlich
ist das kein gewählter präsident bin
wird darauf abschied und das natürlich
ein königshaus da gibt es natürlich noch
ein bisschen anders aber ich finde das
eher positiv sie ist amerikanische
staatsbürgerin
und ich finde es gut und wie sich schon
sagen es ist auch in amerika ist das
geliebte kultur dass menschen die
vielleicht auch in der öffentlichkeit
stehen oder auch er gehört werden
einfach auch über ihre politische
einstellung und gesinnung auch
tatsächlich reden sie erwähnt ja auch
keinen namen das muss man ja und dass
ihr mann aber sich natürlich auf der
anderen seite auch zurückhält ist auch
in ordnung also es kann amerikanischer
staatsbürger und ja der hintergrund aus
dem er stammt gebiet ihm dass das besser
ist sich natürlich zurückzuhalten aber
für sie finde ich das genau ich finde er
hält sich gar nicht so sehr lässt sich
ja vor die kamera zerren setzt sich auf
eine bank wo im hintergrund die hunde
von mengen herumlaufen und das einzige
was ja die kamera sagt ich durfte er in
england nie wählen also das wussten er
sicherlich viele von ihnen sich also
aber wussten auch viele nicht die das
gar nicht so genau wusste dass operativ
wenn du umgehen würde und ich finde dass
du die rolle von mängeln total
unterschätzt also die ist ein vorbild
für viele meiner andere draußen ist hab
ich doch natürlich ist sie ein vorbild
für viele junge frauen und der weg den
sie durchlaufen hat und auch die
entscheidung die sie getroffen hat indem
sie sozusagen auch dieser form des
zusammenlebens sind rücken gekehrt hat
auch das ist ein statement und das finde
ich hoch politisch also die frage ist ja
wie definieren wir politik und ich finde
durchaus dass sie eine politische frau
ist die ihre meinung kundtun sollte
wollen die hat sich wirklich vom
königshaus frei gestrampelt
das muss man auch sie hat sich
emanzipiert entnehmen dass man handeln
die musste sie musste ganz schön viel
einstecken und wann hat man bisher in
reits jahr 2020 macht der mist nicht
mehr mit auch wenn es sich der direkte
vergleich auch wenn ein bisschen hinkt
wie sie gerade schon gesagt habe
nichtsdestotrotz haben sie sich manchmal
damals auch so ein bisschen gefühl zu
und droht als würde man sie mundtot
machen wollen als wenn sie so eine
nebenrolle irgendwie hätten
insgeheim und tod auf jeden fall nicht
und so gesehen ist es ja irgendwie auch
die nebenrolle man weil man in dem fall
also der job das amt ist das amt des
bundespräsidenten hoffentlich bald auch
einer bundespräsidentenwahl
und dann gibt es in partner partnerin
dem fall waren es bisher halt immer
partnerinnen ehefrauen und da ist man
natürlich dann frau von
so hat natürlich ab trotzdem ja einen
eigenen bereich einen eigenen
terminkalender kann es unglaublich viel
bewegen kann themen nach vorne pushen
und auch setzen
aber letztlich ist auch ganz klar
zurückhaltung geboten also gerade
natürlich selber 7 das ist schwer weil
sie sind so eine starke frau dass sie
nicht mal zwischen dieser tage jetzt
reicht's aber macht das doch mal bitte
so und so das kann man ja sagen das kann
man ja im hintergrund auch sagen dass
hinter verschlossenen türen werden ja
auch wird ja auch diskutiert und
gesprochen und das ist sicherlich auch
bei jedem bundespräsidenten der fall mit
frau aber letztlich nach außen ist es
ganz klar deklariert der bundespräsident
die bundespräsidentin wird im amt
gewählt und nicht die ehefrau ergebnis
gibt es ist das was sie vorher nicht
wussten was ihnen dann so schwer
gefallen ist während es anderswo
patrick hat gesagt hat megan hätte es ja
wissen müssen aber was gibt s was wir
nicht wissen wir ja in diesen strukturen
ist was man eigentlich als
selbstbestimmte frau kaum aushält
möglicherweise also was man kaum aushält
kann man jetzt nicht sagen man muss das
auch mal ganz klar sehen wie sie auch
schon im winter natürlich ist es einfach
auch eine unglaubliches privileg
es ist ein großes privileg dort sein zu
dürfen
die bundesrepublik deutschland
präsentieren repräsentieren zu dürfen
das heißt auch dass man sich an
bestimmte auch protokollarische regeln
hält und halten muss weil es das auch
einfacher macht das ist und auch einfach
klare spielregeln wenn verschiedene
kulturen aufeinandertreffen
dass es da einen plan gibt es das da
irgendwie sich alle mit wohlfühlen darum
geht es natürlich auch aber innerhalb
dieses protokolls dieses rahmens ist das
manchmal schon wäre hätte ich mir schon
gewünscht dass es manchmal auch
vielleicht ein bisschen menschlicher
zugegangen wäre ja und dieser stelle
sich wie man sich wirklich
man bekommt eine ahnung natürlich
dadurch wir sage ich jetzt mal nix und
ich wir waren ja auch nicht wir sind da
ja nicht einfach hinein geworfen worden
mein ex mann war vorher jahrelang
ministerpräsident eines bundeslandes da
kann man auch schon ordentlich üben
sozusagen
aber wie es dann wirklich ist wenn man
dann da tatsächlich im amt steht das ist
tatsächlich etwas
man vorher also ich hab mir nicht
vorstellen ich konnte dann doch nicht
letztlich einschätzen was waren die
schwersten momente die man da so hat
also ich stelle mir frau first lady und
trotzdem aber als zweite geige
das ist jetzt eigentlich nichts was
einem hier zuerst mal jugendliche in
ordnung war als zweite geige habe ich
noch nie so betrachtet denn wie gesagt
man hat als frau dann in dem fall des
bundespräsidenten auch einen ganz
eigenen bereich man hat man kann also
man hat erstmals schirmherrschaften
dastehen steht das steht einem frei ob
man die übernimmt oder nicht man kann
auch sagen überhaupt als nicht genau wo
sie noch mal überlegen
und man kann selber themen auch setzen
platzieren und mitbringen so zu sagen
und dann hat man da eine ziemlich große
spielwiese fasst sich auch wirklich
dinge zu bewegen menschen einzuladen
auch sozusagen sichtbar zu machen was in
deutschland alles getan wird wie für
ehrenamtliche tätigkeiten viele
ehrenamtliche power ist in deutschland
gibt das ist eigentlich so die die
themen die man als frau des
bundespräsidenten wirklich nach vorne
nach vorne zeigen kann
auf der anderen seite ist es ja auch
nicht wirklich ein politisches amt
ja aber ganz ganz gut sie haben eben
gerade nämlich satt bevor wir davon ganz
bekommen es wäre schön wenn es eine
bundespräsidentin gh wenn ja warum und
wer käme dafür in frage wer so etwas
wäre der wehr ihre wunschkandidatin
dafür den wenn sie also da würde ich
würde ich da würde ich mich komplett aus
halten natürlich umsonst was wäre
natürlich ist einfach das wäre ein
starkes zeichen und ich glaube das wäre
das wäre das stünde unserem land auch
gut zu wissen dass wir jetzt nur sagen
ich habe immer kanzlerin ja dann auch
die zeit natürlich reif ist irgendwie
und eu-kommissarin präsidentin und und
also wirklich starken frauen die er
schon vorne sind
das sagt zum beispiel und könnte jetzt
doch auch noch x mal schauen das
sicherlich geeignete kandidatinnen
sozusagen für die erste
bundespräsidentin
da müssen sie uns ja einige ausschüsse
also quoten er für quotenfrauen
landwirte halte ich nichts aber genauso
wie es hieß großer die kandidaten gäbe
gibt es sicherlich auch frauen
die das super machen nur wie sie sind
gegen die frau wollte also per se für
eine frauenquote bin ich nicht ahaus
krieg und und versuche mich sehr
interessieren bei mir fällt spontan kein
name ein dir auf wen wir dich gerne
wollen wir einen pakt sind merkel oder
der schönste von der leyen ist auch eine
gute und den orden können geht japan war
im gespräch immer dort käßmann war mal
im gespräch
ich finde das schade wenn wir keine frau
ein feld also es gibt genug ich hab doch
ein paar grad ja ja genug tolle frauen
in unserem land frau wohlfeld kein name
tatsächlich tatsächlich aber ich glaube
es müsste auch nicht unbedingt jemand
sein der sowieso schon im politischen
betrieb so unheimlich verwoben und drin
ist es könnte ja auch mal jemand
sozusagen außerdem fachfremde seien aus
einem ganz anderen mit einem ganz
anderen hintergrund
das stünde vielleicht einfach der der
ganzen ja und dieser position und diesem
ganzen betrieb war ganz gut ich habe
noch eine frage weil mich das wirklich
interessiert sie sind jemand der
wirklich eine tolle ausstrahlung hat
wenn sie einen raum rein kommen und ich
finde nicht dass sozusagen zweite geige
oder so das passt überhaupt nicht
hatten sie manchmal das gefühl dass sie
sozusagen auch mit ihrem auftreten in
ihrem wesen das was sie aus man auch das
protokoll konfrontiert habe mit einer
art und weise dass es herausforderungen
dargestellt
ich glaube das hat eher was damit zu tun
mit der ganz neuen situation auf beiden
seiten also ich sage mal bisher waren da
eben eher ältere herrschaften im haus
gewesen so zu sagen da war es waren
ältere bundespräsidenten ohne you kleine
kinder die ja noch irgendwie mit mit mit
dabei waren das keine patchworkfamilie
und die konstellation war einfach neu
und für uns ja auch und habe gab es
einfach klar gab es erstmal muss zuerst
gab es ein annäherungsprozess und das
war selbstredend am anfang einfach
vieles anders als bei den vorgängerinnen
vorgängern in dem fall aber letztlich
und wir sagen das war ja nicht das war
kein wirkliches problem das gibt's
überall wenn sie neuen job beginnen
antreten egal ob das in der wirtschaft
es sonst wo dann
sie sich ja erstmal akklimatisieren dann
lernt sie die neuen kolleginnen und
kollegen kennen und dann irgendwann
erzählt so vielleicht auch mal ein
bisschen wie es bei ihnen zu hause so
ist und dann ja dann dann wächst
ich wollte jetzt eigentlich wollte
eigentlich auch ein bisschen sollten wir
sie schreiben ja auch in ihrem buch so
ich war oft im innersten nicht zufrieden
mit mir oder zum beispiel auch sehen
darüber geschrieben wie sehr sie sich
dem protokoll auch anpassen mussten ich
meine emotionen jegliche gefühlsregung
öffentlichen auftritten muss sich
unterdrücken was ich wirklich dachte das
muss ich für mich war ja das ist doch
irre druck der jagiellonen damit muss
man leben sondern das ist doch
wahnsinnig man aber man ist auf der
einen seite natürlich im druck
ausgesetzt weil die öffentlichkeit eben
da ist man ist sehr präsent
auf der anderen seite dieses ich konnte
durfte nicht zeigen reflektiert er etwas
von mir selber ich hatte selber einen
anderen anspruch daran ich habe selber
gedacht ich muss so und so sein ich muss
ich muss natürlich dann ein starkes
perfektes bild abgeben
von einer souveränen frau die die so die
situation im griff hat aber das war mit
36 37 jahren in dem fall war das ja
nicht immer wirklich der fall also
natürlich war ich an so vielen momenten
auch einfach von diesem ganzen drumherum
wie jeder andere mensch das auch gewesen
wäre
auch einfach
überfordert oder im positiven sinne auch
ein geplättet
also es ist einfach momente wo man
selber im nachhinein edward da war ich
jetzt dabei so ich bin ja auch sozusagen
dann auch ganz normal wieder nach hause
gegangen habe meine kinder ins bett
gebracht und darf dann abends auf dem
sofa und habe manchmal gedacht ich muss
mich einfach zwicken ich habe jetzt
gerade den papst heute getroffen ich
habe michelle obama mit michelle obama
tee getrunken das kann doch nicht sein
das war jetzt erst stand somit aber sie
macht man nicht mal so ganz oft auch
einfach heulend auf dem sofa wenn man
sagt dass es also ich meine kinder ins
bett bringen den ganzen tag lächeln
händeschütteln permanent seinen
perfekten runde alles meinen keinen
blick auslassen der also unter
beobachtung steht ich meine da sitzt man
noch abends da und sagt also es ist ist
es eher so dass man dass es schön ist
wenn man überhaupt mal auf dem sofa
sitzt das als erstes und das waren dann
war ich einfach mal beine hoch und
sozusagen obligatorische jogging hose
anziehen kann wenn man das auch sonst
natürlich weichert das war das ja auch
nicht gewohnt
ich war natürlich in niedersachsen an
der seite meines damaligen mann ist auch
viel mit unterwegs aber das war ja nicht
annähernd dieser öffentliche fokus die
in denen es dann hier in berlin gab
und dann ist das auf der anderen seite
auch so dass man oder dass ich häufig
auch gedacht habt ich liebe da einfach
zwei leben irgendwie nah und das eine
ist natürlich auch ist eine öffentliche
rolle und das bild was was da manchmal
von mir dann gezeichnet wurde mit dem
war ich selber auch nicht immer
glücklich ist
das ist einfach ganz schwierig die auf
der der versuch überhaupt es anderen
menschen recht machen zu wollen
er schreibt eigentlich aber das kann man
immer im nachhinein gut sagen jetzt bin
ich ein paar jahre älter habe viel
erlebt und bin auch durch mediale ross
coolen gegangen und deswegen kann ich
jetzt auch weiß ich dass jetzt auch war
ein großer moment hoffte dass ich damals
nicht weiß als die ex mann dass
christian wulff zurückgetreten ist wo
sie standen das daran kann ich mich
tatsächlich sehr sehr gut erinnern
oh ja das glaube ich
die grünen können sie sich erinnern wie
wir es ging ihnen da vor heute
rückblickend bin landet hätten sie das
anders gemacht oder hätten sie also aus
heutiger sicht betrachtet hätte ich
sicherlich anders gemacht weil ich weiß
aber auch dass es damals nicht anders
ging
also das war sozusagen tatsächlich dass
der die der letzte moment nach einer
unbeschreiblichen zeitlang manche sagen
auch mediale hetzjagd oder einfach einer
zeit die extrem war unter einem extremen
druck und trotzdem ja auch immer zu
hause noch nie gesagt eben auch eine
familie zusammenhalten wollen und auch
freunde und so und gedacht habe ich das
ich kann das alles irgendwie nicht mehr
übereinander bekommen eine mischung aus
totaler überforderung und erleichterung
dass es vorbei ist und dann auch
letztlich auch ein gefühl von 4 300
fotografen und journalisten ihr da jetzt
wie eine wand steht ihr bekommt kein
gefühl von mir zu sehen so und weil das
ging dann nicht mehr also wie gedacht so
das geld wirklich nur mir her
das bleibt bei mir und das wirkte nach
außen auf viele kalt ist es passiert
genauso hab ich habe gedacht dass das
bekommt ihr nicht auch noch von uns ihr
habt jetzt versucht uns sozusagen hier
recht zu bringen
wir haben es geschafft das bekommt er
nicht und was hätten sie heute anders
gemacht wenn es der tag heute wäre ich
hätte wahrscheinlich wenn ich wenn ich
da jetzt mit mehr abstand oder mit einem
großem abstand an den tag zurückdenke
dann wäre es mir wahrscheinlich jetzt
möglich trotzdem auch noch natürlicher
sozusagen mit der situation umzugehen
ja tatsächlich ich hätte wahrscheinlich
ich hätte mehr emotionen zeigen können
ich wäre jetzt sicherlich nicht mit
meinem damaligen mann am hals gefallen
weil alles so fürchterlich ist aber
sondern das einfach zu zeigen dass es
natürlich mich und uns extrem
mitgenommen hat das ist menschlich
einfach nicht mehr zu ertragen war auch
und ich glaube das hätte der ganzen
sache auch ganz gut getan
und ich glaube das würde sowieso mal ein
bisschen schwenker zu kriegen wir
sowieso politik ganz gut tun wenn und
dafür wäre jetzt eigentlich auch eine
gute zeit wenn man auch betrachten würde
dass das eben menschen sind und dass es
um menschliche reaktionen geht so das
sind personen die versuchen es so gut
wie möglich zu machen
aber es sind eben auch menschen und die
funktionieren nicht einfach er ist
natürlich aber die erwartung an
politiker auch eine andere und da muss
ich auch sagen dass natürlich die
politiker natürlich den druck haben zu
funktionieren das bringt das amt auch so
ein bisschen mit sich die menschlichkeit
fehlt mir auch oft in der politik finde
ich auch was würden auch aber natürlich
müssen wir schauen dass wir dort
menschen haben die sich korrekt
verhalten diesem druck standhalten
diesem strengen protokoll folgen können
und natürlich dass auch mit einer
gewissen menschlichkeit und und
sympathie wir haben ja wir sprechen ja
nachher noch ein politiker sagt die frau
die quote noch ansprechen war er schnell
so ein kleiner drehte nicht jetzt machen
würde
hört sich einmal kurz besprachen dann
aber kurz mal folgendes macht kurze
frauen foto und dann machen wir die
schleife wieder zurück zu den politikern
ja eigentlich menschlich sein du
eigentlich wünsche das war nämlich über
zwei männer dazu gleich mehr erstmal
frauenquote sein weil wir auch darüber
sprachen andere frieden zu stellen und
mich stellt natürlich ganz unzufriedene
frau zu hören
sie sagt ich bin eigentlich nicht für
die frauenquote und deswegen wird es
mich sehr interessieren warum das so ist
weiß tragen hier nicht darum es gibt bei
mir nicht ums prinzip also prinzipien
halte ich was das angeht ganz falls es
geht um qualifikation um leistung und um
darum dass jemand auch wirklich auch
frauen wirklich gewillt sind und das
finde ich eigentlich viel klüger ob sie
sich in dieses system eigentlich genauso
hinein begeben wollen ich weiß gar nicht
genau was genau richtig ist sich im
aufsichtsrat einfach grundsätzlich eines
sag jetzt mal großen automobil so eine
typische männerdomäne
deswegen fällt es mir ein eines eines
automobilherstellers hinein kotieren
lassen zu wollen wenn ich dann da in
diesem system in diesem männer
dominierten system einfach das abliefern
soll was von den letztlich von allen
anderen mir da von mir verlangt wird
also das alleine glaube ich ist es nicht
wenn ich als frau sage ich will das
machen
ich will in diesem aufsichtsrat weil ich
dann eine eigene philosophie hinter habe
wie ich meine dass man so mit menschen
umgeht und dass man ein unternehmen
lenkt oder oder sag mal mit
kontrollierend einwirken kann dann ist
das was anderes
per se weil 30 frauen im aufsichtsrat
sitzen müssen mich damit hinein
dominieren zu lassen das halt ich
gefallen aber ich gebe ja immer das
gericht es gibt keine frauen
das hat ja auch spritzen vorstellen
hören es gibt ja keine frauen wo die
frauen selber sagen dann besorge ich dir
für das gute frauen und ich kenne genug
frauen die die sich das auch vorstellen
können aber wo ist auch im prinzip ist
leider das ist eine benachteiligung gibt
aufgrund der tatsache dass meine frau
ist also das sozusagen sagen dass
sozusagen die strukturelle
benachteiligung eben dazu führt dass wir
diese geringen zahlen haben in deutschen
aufsichtsräten das ist ja wirklich
beschämend ja und und da dann zu sagen
dass man keine frauenquote befürwortet
ich weiß was sie meinen
es geht um die leistung diese frauen
wollen ja nicht bevorzugt werden weil
sie frauen sind aber sie wollen eben
auch nicht benachteiligt sehr gern und
da gehören auch das schon auch
strukturelle herausforderungen dass man
das auch so zu sagen er wäre schade
deshalb natürlich gerne den die die
wirtschaft beziehungsweise der welt wo
man sagt wir brauchen keine frauen knot
und quote weil wir schaffen es auch so
aber leider ist es tatsächlich noch
nicht mal so weit okay mal weitere
einzige frau im mittelmäßige max
[Musik]